figuring out the best way to motivate H
other people through you know through
these short meetings through the emails
through phone calls whatsapps you know a
corridor making coffee talking with them
in the morning understanding that the
whole work and progress is done and is
done not only you know in time but also
in the way right and fashion that you
believe that things should be done is
you know is very hard H when you start
managing man and you're not the direct
manager of you know the individual
contributors right welcome to 20-minute
leaders just sit back relax and learn
from the leaders of today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get
started 20-minute leaders is a proud
supporter of makeawish Israel and Tech
to peace and is in proud collaboration
with secret cord Ventures J Ventures
Riverside FM Fusion VC
Birthright Excel J impact leap Google
for startups and hippo and in media
partnership with
ctech hello and welcome to 20 minute
leaders today we have Alon Jackson the
CEO and co-founder of ASX security and a
great friend of mine Aster security is
the first appto app security solution
prior to founding asteris Jackson served
as head of R&D group at Automotive cyber
security startup Argus which was
acquired by Continental AG he also
previously served over 12 years in
strategic roles in the cyber security
division of the Israeli military
intelligence unit 8200 where he led the
cloud security division Jackson received
an MSC in computer science with honors
specializing in
[Music]
cryptography Alon Jackson welcome to 20
minute leaders hey hey how are you good
how are you today I'm do awesome well
you're you're relocating in about 2
weeks so you you must be hectic and it's
a it's 1 p.m. right now wherever you are
doing this interview so obviously uh
life as an entrepreneur is is fun and
interesting um alone you're working on
some uh some really really cool company
H we know each other from from our um
you know IDF uh Service uh where you
were managing some some phenomenal work
and quite quite a lot of people and so
it was no surprise to me when when
shortly after you left you you announced
that you're um you're building an
amazing company with with phenomenal
investors and and an amazing friend of
mine is working with you and so that
that's all I need to know that what
you're building is incredible tell me a
little bit about asterisks and then I
want to go back to you and your own
journey and then connect all the dots
together yeah amazing first of all
thanks very much for the worm words and
uh yeah I think uh first and foremost
with Asis what really makes asteris is
of course the people like you said so
not only good friends but amazing people
um and amazing technology so really what
we're doing we're creating the first app
to app security platform to really
change how applications today integrate
and connect H to Enterprises um you know
how you have all these apps today on
like your mobile phone right that asks
for permissions um to access your
contacts or access your uh uh photos and
you're like why does this flashlight
actually need to you know delete my
contacts you know this kind of
permissions um so it's really that but
on the Enterprise level right with th
finding hundreds and thousands of such
Connections in between different third
parties in between different apps right
to core systems of organizations and
this is really what we're here to secure
that's kind of in a nutshell amazing so
now take me back a little bit to your
own your own background you know a
technologist by training then you know
manager for for quite some time in a
very high high paced you know critical
environment what what has your own
Journey been like leading up to
asteris yeah so yeah before asteris
actually you know I left A200 the the
cyber security unit and I joined Argus
um Automotive cyber security company so
I led the Rd group over there um really
what we did is kind of you know hacking
into cars and then trying to fix it of
course um and I learned a lot there from
amazing group of Founders uh so that
that was the last couple of years I
think it was important for both myself
and my partner Adan um you know to leave
the A200 bubble and learn a thing or two
outside in the industry um before
building our own baby um yeah and before
that so over 11 years at A200 so quite a
long arm career there left as a miniator
yeah I think A200 you know I'm sure you
know it and most probably lot of the
audience is really the best school in
the world for technology right and for
really Management in you know in in
stressful situations in a lot of
uncertainty situation so it's a good
it's a good school you know to grow up
as both both a technologist and a
manager I think um yeah my last position
there so I was really in charge of the
cloud operations so this of course has a
lot to do in what we're doing with as
just from the other side of the coin um
yeah for that so many different
leadership position and on position I
can see your smiling you know a lot
about what's what was going on there um
yeah so that's a kind of you know if if
you're taking me into your brain and
you're taking me into the way that you
know Jackson is thinking about things
what what do you get really excited
about in general you know when it comes
to these professional this professional
world where where do you find your own
join excitement if you look over these
let's say last 15 years or so yeah I
think that's a good question and maybe
maybe despite you know the world
professional despite the world
technology everywhere I think what I'm
excited the most is really the
generations of team leaders and you know
people that I've worked with um both in
Argus manag like four teams and all team
leaders are good friends of mine today
some of them you know grew to be their
own entrepreneurs today CTO um head of
groups their selves amazing people you
know you kind of H take with you along
the way also before that to day 200 so I
managed a couple of teams with you know
amazing people who you can see them
really progress right you could see them
sometimes start as tech leads then
become first
managers um yeah I think that that's the
biggest thing it's all about people
right and uh and growing together and
growing your network together I think
that's the part part that really excites
me the most and thinking about being a
Founder um I think it's really the
opportunity H to build something from
the ground up right build the
organization you always believed H You
Want To Have and Have you know a good
company that people enjoy right enjoy
coming into and fulfilling themselves
and yeah I think that's the biggest kind
of opportunity and and joy that I kind
of you know the privilege that I had
both here and before all right are you
ready to dive deep into what you're
doing sure let's
so app TOA Integrations let's paint
painted picture um so that we just
everybody's on the same page what is the
world that we're living in now that
makes app to app security an important
part of what's Happening yeah so really
apps are becoming more and more like
platforms today so they enable end users
to build and connect on top of them um
it could be you know from the business
side that add you know extensions
add-ons plugins stuff like that it could
be engineer Engineers that generate API
Keys tokens these are all really
different words that actually mean
abilities to integrate and uh work in a
more automatic way and not for and not
Manual of course um with our with our
apps and really this is important for
the large applications because it makes
them sticky right uh building on top of
them makes you know really they are sure
that you know you won't be able to leave
very very easily um it's a growth engine
for them cuz there's a lot of innovation
being built on top of these platforms um
yeah and the end users today they just
add new apps from bottom up right the
the it is really
democratizing um so there's not always a
procurement process there not always
always a security process when they
adding new third parties new apps on top
of a on top of a Enterprise accounts um
yeah and really no app today is in you
know worth when in in Silo right data is
only worth when shared um this is the
kind of world we live in where
everything is interconnected with
everything via API and this is the kind
of world that the ASX is enabling um to
both map monitor and
secure right so it's obviously it's you
know it's critical that we that that we
have that security layer how do you
productize something like that so when
you actually think about you know the
world and and where ASX is coming into
these
organizations what what what are some
potential products that that are
relevant in in the space here yeah I
think the easiest way to kind of think
about it is that there's so many
solutions out there for user access
right um but there's nothing to help
organizations today manage and secure
all the nonuser access that they have
right and there's single sign on there
there's tofa all these kind of security
mechanisms that help today uh manage and
control really how users access core
platforms but the apis really go under
the radar right there's nothing to help
security managers today um get
visibility um into what's going on there
and really what we're doing in asri is
enabling them for the first time right
both get the visability governance and a
first automatic remediation into how all
their third parties are interconnected
with each other um yeah and actually
there you know the last year was crazy
in terms of a different kind of hacks um
we had GitHub that was a hacked via
third parties from auku and Travis yeah
it was a quite a famous One not long ago
before that we had mail CH before that
we had OCTA before that we had COV all
these just names of incidents of third
parties right that were hacked and
really we call it Service Supply Chain
that's the kind of of what's going on
right it's different services that
really interconnect with each other
right and so as you're approaching the
market and and obvious ly you know
you're you're growing fast you mentioned
you're more than 20 people now you know
just a year later so it's pretty
phenomenal but what's the reception like
I mean where are there you know is is
the market ready for this do seos and
people just generally really understand
the pain Point here and what are you in
terms of the timing on your analysis
yeah yeah so really you know we're
seeing the API ecosystem exploding right
and the last attacks like in the last
year are crazy you know we kind of
laughing sometimes at saying you know
may maybe asteris is behind some of
these attacks uh but no you know it's
actually just a huge wave um that on the
one side you know it's not a good thing
right but it really means that there is
a place for that um yeah we already have
you know large paying customers uh
public companies really amazing
amazing companies so far and you know
it's becoming easier and easier as also
we progress right um today I find you
know when I ask C you know do you manage
user access to your critical systems and
the answer is like 99% yes of course I
do and then you ask like do you manage
API access to your critical systems not
like Jackson what are you talking about
right let's Talk's right so it's kind of
that easy um to understand that there is
a a a big gap in most organizations uh
simply because they don't have the tools
um to actually deal with it right um so
a lot of the time they know that they
have the problem and we did we did talk
actually with with some Enterprise that
you know really looked for this kind of
tool tried to build it by themselves
right tried to manually figure out and
when we came over it was like yeah you
know this was something that we've been
struggling with in the past year and
that's I think the most amazing response
a Founder can get yeah I I love it so so
take me the vision of Aster few years
down the line what what is the role that
asz is playing in the security space and
you know because essentially what what
also part of the you're saying you know
we understand that there's this trend
where we have these growing apps as
platforms you know it's this whole
decentralization process that now every
company is using the an abundance of
these third party apps and and and
you're tackling one of the underlying
issues that are going to perhaps inhibit
some companies from growing as fast as
they want to grow um or to get the
compliance that they need Etc so you're
you're effectively pushing you know the
envelope to to to allow companies to do
that can do this faster and safer what
is the vision for as down the line and
and what is the impact this is going to
have on the industry if you had to
imagine yeah sure so really we're going
into world where we're going to have
more and more third parties right and
the value is only provided when you know
integrating them with each other and the
and them playing with each other and the
Enterprise level um and this is really
what pushes automation this is what
pushes H productivity H forward
and you think like of the cloud Wars
right so we have these big cloud
platforms and theyve been challenged by
more and more other platforms so it's
it's going to be fragmented and they're
going to have to learn to play with each
other just like we're seeing H that is
happening and asri is really going to be
the glue right H between all these
different cloud services because each
cloud service may may do the best job
right with itself and its platform and
how things work with internally but
between them that's that's a hard place
to manage especially for large
organizations um so really being the
integration Hub right being the port in
which Enterprises are connecting with
third parties CU this is where
Innovation comes in this is where
productivity comes in you can't really
stop that you can't really stop the
business um from running forward and
it's you know it's complex it's a mess
and this cross Cloud e connectivity
really is only going to get even more
complex as as times goes by and really
want to help CES so so security manager
progress from being you know Gatekeepers
into productivity enablers right so
enabling their businesses to actually
adopt enabling them to connect and build
right in a more secure way uh in regards
you know to what they can do today today
it's a either yes or no right um it's
kind of B binary and now they can say
yes but you know through asteris right
um so that's a big thing that's a big
change in like you know the physics of
how of how things are enabled today
so you you've gotten a chance to to
manage reset manage and reset again
quite a few teams over over these last
15 years right and you you've had these
opportunities to sort of reset your
management style and rethink because
you've Jo either joining a new
organization creating a new organization
so if you're thinking now about what
you've learned about yourself your own
leadership style the things that are
important to you things that you realize
now are less important than they thought
they were
you know take me into alone's world of
leadership what what what have you
learned over these years yeah I think
the most important thing I learned is a
is Letting
Go um that's the truth kind of
delegating and thinking you know do I
really have to be here do I have to be
the one that does this um this really
empowers right ER empowers your folks um
to do more by themselves and really
enables you H to look forward so so this
is something you know as as the first
time managing managers um you have to
really practice and uh kind of get into
the State of Mind of delegating um but I
think the more maybe interesting I thing
maybe a good story I remember H the
first time I managed the team leads so
we had you know a big u a big meeting at
my office and there were maybe you know
10 people some of them were my team lead
some of them from other teams from other
groups and everything and you know we
planned how we're going to break down
this project and make it happen then you
know in no time we have to win right
that's how things are always
done and then you know after like maybe
half an hour quite a quick discussion
everybody kind of left the room and I
stayed there by myself I really remember
the kind of loneliness of U of staying
by myself in in the office and everybody
was you know running out there in in
their different offices H doing what we
just decided we have to do and I
remember thinking to myself okay so are
they actually going to do it the way you
know I want them to do it or I believe
they should do it be is the spirit there
right um what's going on in the other
rooms um and kind of figuring out the
best way to motivate H other people
through you know through these short
meetings through the emails through
phone calls whatsapps you know a
corridor making coffee talking with them
in the morning understanding that the
whole work and progress is done and is
done not only you know in time but also
in the way right and fashion that you
believe that things should be done is
you know is very hard H when you start
managing managers and you're not the
direct manager of you know the
individual contributors right um I
remember this kind of a a first time and
from then um you really start thinking
you know via culture U what kind of
culture do I build um what kind of
mentorship do I provide to my managers
right for them to H to really um guide H
their guys uh what kind of kpis right do
I point to and put them as as general
and as far as possible right um that's
kind of I think the basic tools that you
really develop across the
years incredible Alon um if you had to
think of what what do you enjoy most in
your day to-day
the thing you enjoy most in in your
journey and what what comes to mind
where what do you find the most
fulfillment yeah yeah so I think it's
kind of a motive that goes really
through a lot of this talk but really is
people right first and for the team the
team uh really a team of amazing people
who joined the who joined the journey
first of all I'd say you know my partner
start with that um so we know each other
for a long time and when I say actually
a long time it's not five years or 10
years it's over 15 years now so we were
recruited yeah we were recruited today
together to an army like Excellence
Military Academy called Kat salot um so
we spent a long time we even lived
together you know six years half of that
you know the Army enforced us the other
three years was you know our own free
will of U of living together uh we did
we did quite a lot um Edan my co-founder
and CTO he also served over a decade in
in A200 actually left the unit also
joined the cyber security startup over
here um deep Instinct the company does
machine learning based endp Point
protection um in the last couple of
years so so kind of joining forces after
that you know we learned a lot both at
the unit and from the industry and we
brought more importantly maybe from the
kind of a technological diversity is the
network diversity right amazing people
who kind of H came very quick and just
like in maybe two weeks we had eight
eight guys joining us and you know uh
the first I remember the first customer
deployment in only three weeks U so
everything kind of runs very fast when
you have amazing people with you um yes
I think the first and foremost is the
co-founder right the team um then
amazing customers H that really start up
as good design Partners right that you
trust and you see eye to eye and believe
First of and foremost again us people
right your ability to execute your
vision um and really enable you to you
know they give your time their time
right they give you their data in the
beginning you don't really have a
product right um just the will and the
vision um so that's you know an amazing
an amazing um Step of trust um from
customers and then amazing investors um
so both the guys from F2 here in Israel
and and besser also the Israel Israel
guys in besser followed by venrock a um
um a Bay Area um VC fund and some
amazing cyber security Angels uh that
joined this round so really so happy you
know to have them as our backers and
yeah and again it all comes down to uh
to people people that believe in you
believe in their ability to execute um I
think that's the best thing you know
spending most of my time um really
talking inspiring
motivating H pushing forward um everyone
I think that's the that's the main role
right and that's what I enjoy the
most alone best of luck with as thank
you so much for for the time and such a
such an awesome Journey amazing a
problem space can't wait to to see what
happens with this company and hope to
the hope that makes a large impact on
this industry so thank you again best of
luck and uh stay safe and stealthy and
good luck on the relocation
thanks very much M thanks for having me
here